Donc comme je l'ai dit, aujourd'hui nous allons nous attarder sur ce premier point.
Donc le premier point du chapitre 7, c'est la destruction totale qui va mettre fin à cette vie misérable caractérisée par leur idolâtrie.
Nous allons chercher à comprendre ce que Dieu était en train de mettre en emphase là-dessus.
Est-ce que nous devons comprendre pour nous qui sommes arrivés à la fin des temps ?
Et c'est aussi une réflexion très intéressante aussi pour nous qui sommes en train d'arriver à la fin de cette année.
Donc dans la continuité, avant d'aborder ce premier point qui rappelle la destruction totale,
on voit que dans la continuité de la fin du chapitre 6, donc entre la fin du chapitre 6 et le début du chapitre 7,
Dieu encourage le prophète à signifier par ses propos.
Donc il devait le montrer, ça devait être visible.
Il n'allait pas juste parler, mais il devait le manifester aussi par ses attitudes,
que la chute du pays d'Israël était imminente.
Le prophète devait aussi montrer que c'est quelque chose qui le touchait.
Il n'était pas juste en train d'être indifférent à ça.
Il n'était pas juste en train de délivrer un message sans la compassion qui va avec.
Il n'était pas juste en train de manifester du mépris, non.
Il avait de la compassion.
Il était affecté par ce qui était en train d'arriver.
Et même si ses auditeurs n'étaient pas en train de réaliser la gravité de la situation,
lui, il devait pouvoir le montrer.
L'aspect qui est donné un peu, c'est comme Mathieu Henri va le dire à un moment,
il va dire que si vous voyez une ville qui est en feu, même une maison qui est en feu,
quand des hommes vont voir un incendie, ils ne vont pas commencer à réciter un poème.
Ils ne vont pas commencer à réciter un poème.
Ils ne vont pas commencer à chercher des expressions françaises élaborées.
Non, ils vont dire au feu.
Ils vont crier.
On va crier.
Il y a le feu.
On ne va pas chanter une sérénade.
Et c'était dans ce sens que Dieu était en train de parler à Ézéchiel.
Ézéchiel devait, dans son expression, il était en train de rappeler qu'il y avait le feu.
Même si Israël ne voyait pas la gravité de la chose.
Et donc pour aborder ce premier point, ce premier point de comprendre cet aspect de destruction totale,
nous voyons au verset 2.
Donc on voit au verset 2, il est dit, la fin vient sur les quatre extrémités.
Au verset 3, il rappelle, la fin vient sur toi.
Au verset 6, il rappelle encore que cette fin va venir.
Quand Dieu est en train d'assister ainsi, il est en train d'annoncer que la fin qui arrive va mettre un terme à leur méchanceté envers lui.
Il est en train d'annoncer que cette fin, c'est la fin finale vers laquelle ont tendu tous les jugements.
C'est-à-dire, depuis Moïse, lorsque Dieu s'est acquis ce peuple,
dès l'instant où ce peuple a péché jusqu'à présent avec ce royaume de Juda,
la fin dont Dieu est en train de parler, c'est la fin finale que tous les jugements qui ont eu lieu pendant tous ces siècles étaient en train d'annoncer.
Donc ce sont tous les jugements depuis Moïse jusqu'au dernier roi d'Israël
qui étaient en train d'annoncer cette fin finale.
Cette fois-ci, il est en train de dire, la ruine sera complète.
Ils ne seront pas épargnés comme ils l'ont pu l'être dans les siècles précédents.
Et si vous étudiez la parole, vous allez voir un moment qu'il n'y a jamais eu de guerre totale en tant que telle.
Quand vous lisez le livre des juges, vous allez remarquer que c'était une partie des tribus qui allaient être attaquées par un peuple voisin,
mais ce n'était jamais tout Israël qui allait forcément être en guerre.
Peut-être sauf sur la période de David.
Mais chaque fois, c'était par exemple, pour vous dire, c'est la tribu de Dan qui a attaqué.
Donc ce n'était pas une guerre totale.
Mais cette fois-ci, Dieu est en train de leur dire que ce ne sera pas comme les siècles précédents.
Ce ne sera pas comme ce que vous avez pu constater,
où plusieurs fois vous vous êtes repentis après, et vous êtes revenus, et vous avez encore péché.
Non.
Cette fois-ci, la fin sera totale.
Pour comprendre le type de fin dont la Bible est en train de nous parler,
nous pouvons comparer cette fin au jugement qui est arrivé via le déluge.
C'est la même fin quand on parle.
C'est la même fin quand on parle du déluge.
C'est le même type de fin quand on parle de la destruction de Sodome et Gomorre par le feu.
C'est le même type de fin dont on parle et qui nous permet d'avoir un aspect visuel.
Ça nous permet aussi de comprendre un peu.
Mais c'est aussi une fin qui est en train d'illustrer.
Et c'est aussi intéressant parce que le Seigneur Jésus-Christ, c'est-à-dire Dieu lui-même,
va prendre ces exemples pour nous rappeler un moment ce type de fin.
Ce jugement qui était en train d'arriver sur Israël
était aussi en train de préfigurer le jugement final dans l'histoire de l'humanité déchue dans laquelle nous sommes.
Le Seigneur Jésus-Christ va rappeler aux personnes qui étaient en train de l'écouter dans Luc 17, versets 26 à 30.
Il va dire un moment,
« Ce qui arriva du temps de Noé arrivera de même au jour du Fils de l'homme. »
Donc il est en train d'insister.
C'est cette même fin dont il est en train de parler.
Cette fin que nous voyons dans le déluge, dans la destruction de Sodome et Gomorre,
que nous voyons dans la destruction de Jérusalem,
à l'époque des Babyloniens et plus tard, à l'époque même des Romains,
doit nous enseigner qu'il y aura une fin finale
qui arrivera lorsque Dieu mettra un terme à la méchanceté ici-bas.
Le Seigneur Jésus-Christ dit, verset 27,
« Les hommes mangeaient, buvaient, se mariaient et mariaient leurs enfants
jusqu'au jour où Noé entra dans l'arche.
Le déluge vint et les fit tous périr.
Ce qui arriva du temps de Lot arrivera pareillement. »
Donc là, on parle de l'épisode de Sodome et Gomorre.
« Les hommes mangeaient, buvaient, achetaient, vendaient, plantaient, bâtissaient.
Mais le jour où Lot sortit de Sodome,
une pluie de feu et de soufre tomba du ciel
et les fit tous périr.
Il en sera de même le jour où le Fils de l'homme paraîtra. »
Ce n'est pas un mythe.
Ce n'est pas un mythe qui nous est raconté là.
La Bible est en train, Dieu lui-même,
est en train de certifier qu'il y aura une fin finale
pour cette humanité déchue.
En Israël, lorsque Ézéchiel est en train de leur parler,
beaucoup se berçaient d'illusions
en imaginant qu'ils allaient être délivrés par leurs idoles
ou ils allaient même être délivrés par Dieu
parce qu'à un moment, ce qu'ils faisaient,
ils avaient conscience à un moment du mal qu'ils faisaient vis-à-vis de Dieu.
Et quand ils avaient conscience du péché,
ils essayaient de rétablir le culte de l'Éternel
tout en gardant le culte de leurs idoles
parce qu'ils se disaient à un moment,
dans une forme de superstition,
que Dieu allait peut-être les sauver comme il l'avait fait avant.
Donc ils espéraient être délivrés soit par leurs idoles,
soit par Dieu, soit par l'Égypte et son Pharaon.
Mais vous voyez, ce sont les mêmes personnes
à qui Jérémie avait envoyé une lettre.
Quand nous lisons dans Jérémie,
c'est un des passages aussi aujourd'hui
qui est beaucoup utilisé dans les églises
et même déformé.
Quand il va dire à un moment,
je vous appelle à être en bénédiction
dans la nation dans laquelle je vous ai placé,
je vous ai bénis pour leur donner de la paix
et non du malheur.
Et c'est à ces mêmes personnes
que Jérémie avait envoyé cette lettre.
Il était en train de leur signaler
que l'espérance que vous portez un jour
de pouvoir rentrer à Jérusalem,
elle n'aura pas lieu.
Mais au contraire,
Dieu vous demande de prendre racine à Babylone
et d'y construire votre vie.
Donc, ce n'était pas la fin
qu'il est en train d'annoncer
aux captifs à Babylone,
ce n'est pas la fin qu'il est en train d'annoncer
pour le reste du pays d'Israël.
Pour le reste du pays d'Israël,
il est en train de leur annoncer la fin
que Moïse leur avait annoncée.
Et souvenez-vous,
il y a quelque temps,
nous avions lu une série de passages
dans Deutéronome
où nous voyons que tous ces jugements
qui se manifestent au temps d'Ézéchiel
avaient été annoncés
avec précision
par Moïse
en leur disant
« Si un jour vous vous détournez de l'Éternel,
voici tout ce qui vous arrivera. »
Et voilà donc la fin
que Moïse leur avait annoncée.
Donc, ce n'était pas une fin de prospérité,
mais c'était la fin
qui se manifestait
parce qu'Israël avait oublié
son alliance avec son Dieu.
Donc, plusieurs siècles
après les avertissements
de Moïse dans Deutéronome,
c'est cette fin
qui avait été
tant de fois repoussé.
Et c'est intéressant de voir
que plusieurs fois,
Dieu aurait pu
arriver à cette fin ultime
pour Jérusalem.
Mais plusieurs fois,
Dieu a repoussé
son jugement
à cause de sa patience.
Nous devons toujours nous rappeler
et nous ne devons pas nous tromper là-dessus
et surtout même
souvent pour nous chrétiens.
Il y a des moments
quand nous regardons,
nous lisons les journaux,
nous regardons la vie,
nous voyons tellement d'injustices
et nous avons souvent l'impression
que le méchant prospère.
Nous avons l'impression
que pour certaines personnes,
rien n'arrivera de leur vivant.
Elles pourront même partir,
elles peuvent même partir
dans la mort tranquillement
sans avoir à rendre des comptes
du mal qu'elles ont fait ici-bas.
Mais nous ne devons pas nous tromper.
Même si la ruine des méchants
peut nous paraître lente,
une chose ne doit pas nous échapper,
elle est inévitable.
Dans sa sainteté,
dans sa justice,
Dieu ne tolère pas le péché.
Et quand nous parlons du méchant,
ici, quand je parlerai du méchant,
je suis en train de mettre l'aspect
sur ceux qui rejettent Dieu
et ses commandements.
Et quand nous lisons
les propos du Seigneur Jésus-Christ
qui ont été lus tout à l'heure,
dans Luc 17,
nous voyons que les manifestations
temporaires du jugement de Dieu
sont un avant-goût
pour nous rappeler
du jugement final
du monde impie
dans lequel nous sommes.
Chrétiens,
nous devons voir
que chaque fois que nous voyons
des manifestations de jugement
par rapport au péché humain,
chaque fois que nous voyons
des manifestations de jugement de Dieu
même dans notre vie
quand nous avons péché,
nous devons au contraire
nous réjouir
parce que nous savons
que notre Dieu est juste
et nous savons que notre Dieu
est vrai dans ce qu'il dit.
mais tous ces jugements temporaires,
tous ces jugements qui sont arrivés
à Sodome,
le déluge,
parce que toute l'humanité
n'a pas été détruite
pendant le déluge,
Dieu a toujours épargné un reste.
Regardons cet aspect
où dans la destruction,
dans le déluge,
il s'épargne un reste
pour que ce reste puisse témoigner
et revenir à lui.
avec l'autre,
il va s'épargner un reste
et même si c'est une histoire
assez tordue,
nous voyons aussi
comment quelque part
par rapport au fait
que l'autre craignait l'éternel,
Dieu l'avait épargné.
Quand nous regardons
Israël qui est jugé,
Jérusalem qui est jugé,
Dieu s'épargne un reste
pour que ce reste puisse
se repentir
et témoigner
de sa grandeur
et il en sera de même.
Au travers de l'église,
Dieu s'épargne un reste
qui va connaître
la repentance
et qui va pouvoir témoigner
que notre Dieu est grand.
Il y a des moments
où le jugement de Dieu
peut nous paraître lent
ou pas du tout réel,
même pour certaines personnes.
Si vous faites
un micro-trottoir dans la rue
et vous demandez
à des personnes
est-ce que tu crois
que le jugement de Dieu
va venir ?
Des personnes vont dire
je n'y crois pas.
Et d'ailleurs même
dans certaines églises,
j'ai rencontré des pasteurs.
Une fois,
ils m'ont invité
à partager la parole
et ils m'ont dit
surtout tu ne parles pas
de jugement,
de l'enfer
parce que pour certains,
dans certains milieux chrétiens,
le jugement n'existe pas
en tant que tel.
Notre Dieu n'est juste
qu'amour
et il peut fermer
les yeux sur tout.
Et c'est déjà
une très mauvaise compréhension.
La Bible nous enseigne
que le jugement final
de l'humanité déchue
aura bien lieu.
Et le Seigneur Jésus-Christ
nous en parle.
Et j'avais déjà pris aussi
ce message pour rappeler
ce que Pierre nous dit
encore là-dessus.
Et c'est toujours intéressant
de pouvoir relire ces choses
quand nous lisons par exemple
dans 2 Pierre 3
versets 1 à 4
qui va dire
Voici déjà bien aimé
la seconde lettre
que je vous écris.
Dans l'une et dans l'autre
je cherche à éveiller
par des avertissements
votre saine intelligence.
Donc soyons conscients.
C'est quelque chose
qui doit nous rester à l'esprit.
Lorsque je suis en train d'arriver,
lorsque je suis en train
de débuter une année,
que je suis en train
d'établir mes buts,
de penser à ma vie
tout au long de cette année,
je dois me souvenir
que Dieu reviendra,
que le Seigneur Jésus-Christ
reviendra,
que le jugement de Dieu
aura lieu.
Quand je suis en train
d'arriver à la fin de l'année,
que je suis en train
de faire le bilan
de cette année,
je dois aussi voir
est-ce que ce paramètre
de la crainte de Dieu,
de ce retour de Christ
a été intégré
dans la façon
dont j'ai vécu cette année.
C'est dans ce sens
que Pierre est en train
de nous dire
que voilà des avertissements
qui doivent éveiller
notre saine intelligence.
Il va dire
afin que, verset 2,
afin que vous vous souveniez
des choses annoncées
d'avance par les saints prophètes
et du commandement
du Seigneur et Sauveur
enseignés par vos apôtres.
Sachant avant tout
que dans les derniers jours,
il viendra des moqueurs
avec leur raillerie,
marchant selon
leur propre convoitise
et disant
où est la promesse
de son avènement.
Car depuis que les pères
sont morts,
tout demeure
comme dès le commencement
de la création.
Mais il y a une chose
bien aimée
que vous ne devez pas ignorer.
Et c'est là
où nous parlons
de la patience de Dieu.
C'est que devant le Seigneur,
un jour est comme mille ans.
Et mille ans
sont comme un jour.
Le Seigneur ne tarde pas
dans l'accomplissement
de la promesse
comme quelques-uns le croient.
Mais il use de patience
envers vous
ne voulant pas
qu'aucun périsse
mais voulant que tous
arrivent à la repentance.
Et il insiste,
le jour du Seigneur,
donc il est en train
de nous confirmer quelque chose
qui aura bien lieu.
Le jour du Seigneur
viendra comme un voleur.
En ce jour,
les cieux passeront
avec fracas,
les éléments embrasés
se dissoudront
et la terre
avec les œuvres
qu'elle renferme
sera consumée.
Donc,
nous voyons
que cette fin de Jérusalem,
ce que Dieu nous enseigne
au travers de cette fin
de Jérusalem,
c'est sa préfigure,
la fin de ce monde.
De même que la destruction
fut totale
pour tout le pays d'Israël,
de même la fin
frappera le monde
tout entier
et tous ses recoins.
Et quand le jugement
de Dieu tombera,
ce ne sera pas
un abri atomique,
comme vous voyez,
il y a beaucoup de riches
qui vont se créer
des abris atomiques,
des abris...
Non,
un abri atomique
ne sauvera pas.
Le fait de se réfugier
dans une forêt profonde
où on va même t'oublier
ne te sauvera pas
du jugement de Dieu.
De même que Israël
a péri dans le feu
avec ses idoles,
ce monde brûlera
avec toutes les idoles
qui s'est faites
et qu'il a choisi
d'adorer
au lieu d'adorer
le Créateur,
notre Dieu
béni éternellement.
De même
que Dieu
a exercé sa patience
sur plusieurs siècles
avant le jugement
d'Israël,
donc nous voyons
comment plusieurs fois
Dieu aurait pu
déjà détruire Jérusalem,
mais dans sa patience
il préserve Jérusalem.
De même,
Dieu donne encore
l'occasion à tout homme
dans sa génération
de pouvoir se repentir.
Dieu exerce
ses jugements temporaires
dans les vies
de chacun de nous
pour appeler
à toutes et à tous
que le jugement final
aura bien lieu.
d'ailleurs,
il est intéressant
de voir que
le problème principal
que des personnes
dites athées
ont avec Dieu,
parce que souvent
on va dire,
quelqu'un va dire
je suis athée,
mais je dis plutôt
des personnes dites athées
qui se disent athées
parce que
la parole de Dieu
va nous dire
à un moment
que en chacun de nous
la pensée de Dieu
est ancrée profondément
et donc même
quand on veut
se convaincre
du contraire,
on ne peut pas
se convaincre.
D'ailleurs,
même pour des athées,
souvent je trouve
qu'ils parlent
beaucoup d'un Dieu
qui devrait être
inexistant.
Mais voilà,
il est intéressant
de voir que
le problème principal
des personnes
dites athées
avec Dieu,
c'est cette idée
que Dieu
puisse avoir
un oeil
sur leur vie.
C'est cette idée
que Dieu puisse être
l'auteur
du jugement temporaire
et même l'auteur
du jugement final.
Ils ont ce problème
avec Dieu
du fait qu'ils ont
du mal
du fait que
Dieu puisse être
en train de juger
l'homme
lorsque l'homme pêche.
Mais
qu'est-ce que
Dieu nous enseigne
au travers
de son jugement?
C'est que
Dieu use de patience
envers le pêcheur
mais il finit toujours
par lui demander
des comptes
pour tout ce qu'il aura fait.
Et comme mes frères
l'ont bien illustré
lorsqu'ils ont
aussi bien
dans l'introduction
de notre frère Christian
que dans
le texte des enfants
de notre frère
Nathanael
c'est enfin
ce qu'ils ont mis
c'est cette conscience
un moment
que tout homme
rendra compte
devant Dieu.
En ayant cette pensée
c'est une pensée
qui effraie
les hommes
qui ne connaissent pas Dieu
mais c'est une pensée
qui doit rassurer
ceux qui le connaissent.
Alors bien sûr là
à ce niveau
quand je suis en train
de parler comme ça
si quelqu'un
écoute pour la première fois
il va se dire
mais en quoi
on peut trouver
de la joie
à comprendre
que Dieu manifeste
ses jugements.
Mais encore plus
en arrivant
à la fin de cette année
et en étant
sur le point d'entrer
dans une nouvelle
prenons encore
plus conscience
que la patience
de notre Seigneur
et notre salut.
Prends conscience
toutes les fois
l'autre jour
j'ai eu l'occasion
de demander
à quelques-uns
j'ai demandé
à des personnes
qui a lu sa Bible
tout au long de l'année
j'ai vu des mains
qui se sont levées
j'ai dit
qu'il y a eu
un moment
un moment de prière
au moins
toute l'année
c'est-à-dire
chaque jour
de cette année
j'ai vu des mains
qui se sont levées
que le Seigneur
vous bénisse
mais
si nous allons demander
on va dire
qui a pu
traverser toute cette année
sans péché
il n'y a aucune main
qui va se lever
ou bien s'il y a une main
qui se lève
alors là
nous allons
discuter avec lui
il a des choses intéressantes
à nous apprendre
mais la vérité
qu'il y a
c'est que nous avons
constaté la fidélité
de Dieu
tout au long de cette année
tu as pu constater
la fidélité
la patience de Dieu
dans ta vie
toutes les fois
où tu as manqué
de patience
envers l'autre
envers ton prochain
tu as vu la patience
de Dieu
envers toi
toutes les fois
où tu as manqué
de fidélité
envers ton prochain
tu as vu la fidélité
de Dieu
envers toi
toutes les fois
où nous avons manqué
d'amour
envers notre prochain
nous avons vu
un amour
inconditionnel
inaltérable
de Dieu
envers nous
une des choses
une des premières choses
pour lesquelles
nous devons remercier Dieu
quand nous arrivons
à la fin de cette année
ne sera pas
de dire
Seigneur
je te remercie
pour telle ou telle chose
pour tel ou tel bien matériel
la première chose
c'est Seigneur
je te remercie
parce que ton salut
s'est encore exercé
sur ma vie
tout au long de cette année
ta fidélité
s'est encore exercé
sur ma vie
tout au long de cette année
nous sommes exhortés
à pouvoir travailler
à être trouvé
sans tâche
et répréhensible
dans la paix de Dieu
nous sommes exhortés
à pouvoir
garder notre vie
afin que notre vie
ne soit pas caractérisée
par l'orgueil
par l'envie
par la convoitise
par l'égarement
des impies
en prenant conscience
que la patience
de notre Seigneur
est notre salut
nous devons faire
tous nos efforts
pour lire davantage
la parole
nous devons faire
tous nos efforts
pour davantage
la mémoriser
pour qu'elle prenne
davantage vie en nous
que cet aspect
cette conscience
de la brièveté
de cette vie
soit toujours
dans nos cœurs
et qu'elle nous amène
à racheter le temps
nous devons être
en train de prier
par la parole
nous devons être
en train de nous édifier
d'édifier nos bien-aimés
par la parole
nous devons faire
tous nos efforts
pour continuer
à aimer
selon la parole
nous devons faire
tous nos efforts
pour continuer
à détester
selon la parole
alors quand je parle
de détester
il s'agit de haïr
ce que Dieu est
et d'ailleurs
c'est un point aussi
qui nous amène
sur le deuxième point
donc là
sur ce premier point
de cette destruction totale
nous voyons un moment
que ça nous enseignait aussi
la destruction totale
de notre monde à venir
mais aujourd'hui
Dieu n'a pas détruit
un monde rempli
de méchanceté
parce que la patience
de Dieu s'exerce encore
envers cette génération
envers toutes ces générations
depuis les siècles passés
dans le deuxième point
et ce deuxième point
il commence
à partir du verset
du verset 5
Dieu parle
il dit
ainsi parle le Seigneur
l'éternel
un malheur
un malheur unique
voici il vient
Dieu parle
d'un mal unique
dans son essence
en tant que tel
le péché
est un mal unique
ne contient
aucun bien
il y a des moments
où
certaines personnes
essayent de donner
une coloration joyeuse
au péché
on essaye de donner
de la légèreté
au péché
on essaye de donner
une excuse au péché
mais
le péché
en son essence
ne contient rien
de bon
le péché
est une offense
contre Dieu
le péché
est
une blessure
directe
portée vis-à-vis
de notre prochain
et
même quand la Bible
nous dit un moment
pour
le péché
le salaire du péché
dans son essence
même on voit
la Bible nous dit
que le salaire du péché
c'est la mort
dans son essence
même
de mal unique
le résultat
du péché
c'est la mort
et nous pouvons même
voir qu'un seul mal
même dans notre exemple
vous voyez
ce péché
d'idolâtrie
le problème de Dieu
à un moment
c'est que le péché
d'idolâtrie
a ouvert la porte
à de nombreux autres
péchés dans la vie
d'Israël
et nous étions venus
sur ce point
où nous étions en train
de parler
que le principe même
d'avoir quelque chose
qui est en train
de supplanter
l'adoration
qui revient à Dieu
dès que nous plaçons
quelque chose
qui prend l'adoration
qui revient à Dieu
nous sommes en train
aussi de pratiquer
l'idolâtrie
mais nous sommes en train
d'ouvrir aussi la porte
à de nombreux autres péchés
et nous voyons
à un moment
que ce péché
d'idolâtrie
a suffi
à détruire
la nation d'Israël
tout entière
comment la fin
vient ainsi
dans cet aspect
où Dieu parle
d'un mal unique
lorsqu'il est en train
l'insiste en disant
la fin vient
elle se réveille
contre toi
la parole de Dieu
souligne
qu'il y a un aspect
de non-retour
la parole de Dieu
souligne
qu'il y a
c'est quelque chose
qui va arriver
qu'on ne pourra pas
voir autrement
et là encore
c'est une exhortation
rends grâce à Dieu
toutes les fois
où le Seigneur
t'a amené
à voir un péché
dans ta vie
à te repentir
d'un péché
à demander pardon
au Seigneur
quand un coeur
a laissé le péché
l'endurcir
au point que
toute forme
de repentance
ou de remise en cause
sont rejeter
il faut savoir
que le jugement
de Dieu
est arrêté
c'est ça qui est terrible
quand vous regardez
l'histoire
à un moment
vous allez lire
l'histoire
de Pharaon
et de Moïse
nous voyons
à un moment
comment
il y a une forme
de repentance
il n'est même plus capable
d'une forme
de repentance
c'est à dire
le jugement de Dieu
est en train
de se manifester
les jugements tombent
les diplées
les uns après les autres
et il est manifeste
que ce n'est pas
le fruit du hasard
mais Pharaon
n'arrive même plus
à se repentir
Pharaon n'arrive même plus
à se remettre en cause
Israël était arrivé
à un point
lorsque Dieu parle
la fin vient
c'est parce que
Israël était arrivé
à un point
où la remise en cause
il ne l'a considéré
même plus nécessaire
ils avaient atteint
un point de non-retour
et là
le jugement de Dieu
est arrêté
les bien-aimés
gardons nos cœurs
si à un moment
ça a été le cas
au cours de cette année
que vis-à-vis
d'un péché
tu n'as plus éprouvé
de peine
et que tu l'as trouvé
comme étant normal
d'être présent
dans ta vie
que tu as même trouvé
une façon
de t'accommoder
de lui
fais attention
à ce que le jugement
de Dieu
ne soit arrêté
et que la patience
de Dieu
ne soit arrivée
à son terme
au contraire
prions
et même
lorsque nous sommes
en train de rentrer
dans cette nouvelle année
prions pour que
Dieu nous donne
nous donne toujours
d'avoir des cœurs
repentants
que Dieu nous donne
d'avoir toujours
des cœurs
qui savent reconnaître
leur tort
vis-à-vis de Dieu
vis-à-vis des hommes
des cœurs
qui savent
demander pardon à Dieu
la finalité du méchant
c'est que le cœur
endurci
va boire le calice
jusqu'à la lit
donc c'est
une expression
c'était
lorsque
on prenait
quand on va prendre
une coupe
et qu'on va boire
tout ce que contient
la coupe
jusqu'à la moindre goutte
on est en train
de parler
que le jugement
de Dieu
sera total
pour le pécheur
pour l'impie
pour celui
qui refuse
de se repentir
mais la miséricorde
de Dieu
sera pour le cœur
repentant
la miséricorde
de Dieu
sera pour celui
qui
qui a
cette capacité
à pouvoir
être lucide
sur l'état
de son cœur
à ne pas se séduire
à un moment
le plus grand danger
j'ai rencontré
beaucoup de personnes
qui ont
cette séduction
où
même quand ils vont
avoir un problème
et c'est là
où on disait
un moment
mais ce serait plutôt
alors que cette personne
s'examine
à un moment
une personne
va avoir un problème
avec
une personne
A
une première personne
et quand elle va dire
à un moment
elle ne voit pas
en quoi elle a mal fait
mais elle voit
le mal dans l'autre
elle va avoir un problème
avec une personne B
elle ne voit pas
en quoi elle a mal fait
elle voit que c'est
l'autre qui a sa faute
et ainsi de suite
et la réalité
à un moment
c'est que
quand vous êtes
des observateurs extérieurs
quelle est la conclusion
c'est que
le problème
n'est peut-être
pas les autres
le problème
c'est celui
qui a le problème
avec tout le monde
mais à un moment
cette personne
manque de lucidité
d'honnêteté même
pour dire à un moment
Seigneur
qu'est-ce qui se passe
dans mon coeur
alors bien sûr
tout le monde
tout ce genre de personnes
ne sont pas forcément
des croyants
mais nous devons être lucides
nous devons être lucides
sur le fait
que
quand nous parlons
de Dieu
qui n'épargnera
personne
pas ce monde
nous devons comprendre
à un moment
que nous aussi
nous étions dans ce monde
nous aussi nous étions
nous étions de ce nombre
qui méritait ce jugement
qui méritait de boire
le calice jusqu'à la lit
l'enseignement
que Dieu nous donne
à un moment
c'est que les châtiments
d'Israël
ont été temporaires
mais nous illustraient
des tourments finaux
des impies
et
qu'est-ce que nous pouvons
comprendre
et j'arrive un peu
aujourd'hui
un peu sous cette conclusion
après ces deux points
que nous avons abordés
donc sur
cet aspect de
destruction totale
mais aussi cet aspect
de ce jugement
arrêté de Dieu
la première chose
dont nous devons
prendre conscience
c'est que nous tous
nous avons été
sous l'empire du péché
et encore plus
lorsque nous sommes
en train d'arriver
à la fin de l'année
et que nous sommes
dans cette période
cette période de Noël
bien que dans certains aspects
elle soit vidée
de son sens
de son rappel
de beaucoup de choses
qu'elle soit
suivie à des polémiques
ou à certaines choses
mais en tant que chrétien
et même ça
depuis que je suis tout petit
bien qu'à un moment
il y ait eu
on va dire des embrouilles
il y avait le père Noël
une des réalités
qui m'a toujours été enseigné
c'est que Noël
nous rappelait
que le Seigneur Jésus-Christ
était venu
Noël nous rappelait
que Dieu était venu
le Dieu est venu
pourquoi ?
parce que même
dans cette humanité déchue
cette humanité
qui méritait
de boire le calice
jusqu'à la vie
Dieu nous a aimés
même lorsque je suis
en train d'examiner ma vie
et que je suis en train
d'arriver à la fin
de cette année
quel est mon constat
Dieu m'a aimé
nous avons été
sous l'empire du péché
la Bible nous dit
à un moment
qu'il n'y avait
personne de juste
pas même un seul
même quand on peut
se séduire à un moment
de penser à un moment
que nous serions sauvés
par de bonnes oeuvres
parce que nous faisons
telle ou telle chose
parce que nous ne péchons
pas plus que d'autres
le Seigneur nous dit
à un moment
que nous étions
tous perdus
nous étions tous
sans un sens
nous n'avions pas
de sens à notre vie
nos bouffes
servaient à faire
du mal à notre prochain
nous avions cette capacité
de nous porter
vers le péché
nous avions cette capacité
de pouvoir nous créer
des idoles
qui offensent Dieu
et une dernière fois
on était en détail
quand on parlait
de qu'est-ce que
le péché d'idolâtrie
peut ouvrir comme porte
qu'est-ce que le péché
d'idolâtrie ouvre
à une multitude de péchés
et nous voyons
par exemple
dans notre nation
le fait
à un moment
de rejeter Dieu
la présence de Dieu
dans beaucoup d'aspects
de vie de la société
qu'est-ce que cela entraîne
ou ça entraîne
l'indifférence
ça entraîne
la solitude
d'un plus grand nombre
ça entraîne
la violence
le fait
que
on va
on va promouvoir
l'adultère
comme étant une chose normale
alors que c'est quelque chose
qui brise des vies
qui brise
des familles
des enfants
la crainte de Dieu
n'était pas dans nos cœurs
nous constatons
un moment
quand nous pensons
au Seigneur Jésus Christ
qui est venu
bébé
dans ce monde
qui est né bébé
grandit
et qui est allé
jusqu'à la croix
c'était pour une humanité déchue
dont nous faisions partie
et malgré tout ce que nous avons pu faire
en pensant
à un moment
que nos œuvres
allaient nous donner de la paix
tout ce que nous avons fait
ne nous a pas donné de la paix
cela nous a donné
encore davantage de troubles
cela nous a conduit
à rechercher
des choses ésotériques
pour trouver la paix
mais nous n'avons pas trouvé cette paix
mais la joie
qui nous a été donnée
c'est que
la parole a été
faite chère
au milieu d'un monde
qui devrait boire
le calice
jusqu'à la lit
au milieu d'un monde
qui ne devrait pas
être épargné
de la colère de Dieu
Dieu est descendu
et Dieu a habité
parmi nous
et comme le dit Jean
un moment
ce Dieu plein de grâce
plein de vérité
ceux qui ont vécu
en son temps
ont pu contempler
sa gloire
la gloire
comme celle du fils unique
venu du père
mais encore plus merveilleux
nous qui n'avons jamais
vu Jésus Christ
de nos propres yeux
nous avons pu
contempler la gloire
du Christ
nous avons pu goûter
combien Christ
est vivant
et le rappel
pour nous
c'est de comprendre
un moment
qu'est-ce que notre Dieu
a fait
pour que nous n'ayons pas
à boire le calice
jusqu'à la lit
notre Dieu
s'est fait homme
et notre Dieu
a porté nos péchés
dès l'instant où il était né
dès l'instant
il est venu ici-bas
il était destiné
à mourir sur la croix
je peux dire
qu'un moment
au milieu de toutes
nos occupations
quotidiennes
de la vie
ce n'est pas des choses
auxquelles nous pensons
de façon spontanée
mais une des choses
qu'il y a
c'est que nous devons
exercer
et c'est ce que Pierre
est en train de nous dire
qui nous rappelle
par
il rappelle par
des avertissements
qui doivent éveiller
notre saine intelligence
doit être éveillée
par le souvenir
de Dieu
qui s'est fait homme
qui est allé mourir
volontairement à la croix
et quand on inclut
dans la mort
nous savons
ce que ça signifie
pour lui
d'avoir
les mains
et les pieds
percés
d'avoir
la côte
brisée
d'avoir
être fouetté
méprisé
battu
alors que c'est le Dieu
qui a façonné
ce monde
de ses mains
mais tout cela
a été accompli
parce que Dieu
dans son amour
avait promis
que là
où Adam
avait échoué
il allait
restaurer
toute chose
c'est une promesse
que Adam
et beaucoup
de ses descendants
portés
ont espéré
au travers
des siècles
puisque même
Moïse
va même
parler du Christ
à venir
les prophètes
vont parler
du Christ
à venir
et un jour
des bergers
dans un champ
ont pu
goûter la gloire
du Dieu
qui venait
parmi nous
nous avons
goûté la gloire
du Dieu
qui vient parmi nous
nous avons pu
constater
que ce Dieu
qui est allé
jusqu'à mourir
à la croix
pour nous
ce Dieu
qui est allé
même jusqu'à
être mis au tombeau
a été ressuscité
non pas pour son
propre plaisir
mais par amour
pour nous
il a été
ressuscité
par le Père
parce qu'il a
vécu une vie
sans péché
afin que nous
n'ayons pas
à boire
la colère
pleine
et totale
de Dieu
et lorsque
nous sommes en train
d'arriver
à la fin
de cette année
nos cœurs doivent
abonder en reconnaissance
de réaliser
combien
l'amour de Dieu
a été manifesté
au travers
de sa mort
et de sa résurrection
combien pour nous
qui étions
pauvres
pour nous
qui étions
totalement perdus
et
c'est à la fois
une beauté
c'est à dire
c'est à la fois
une bénédiction
mais ça peut être
un danger
le chrétien
un moment
avance
par la grâce
de Dieu
sans culpabilité
il avance
avec le fait
d'être béni
de ce que Dieu
a accompli
dans sa vie
mais la chose
qu'il y a
c'est qu'il oublie
d'où il a été tiré
souvent nous allons
oublier
d'où nous avons
été tirés
et chaque fois même
que nous allons
avoir une manifestation
d'impatience
de manque de patience
de manque d'amour
envers notre prochain
de manque de pardon
nous sommes juste
en train de manifester
que nous oublions
la boue du péché
d'où nous avons
été tirés
mais la boue
nous vient au moment
que ce Dieu
pour nous qui étions
totalement brisés
par le péché
pour nous qui n'avions
aucun espoir
pour nous qui étions
dans les ténèbres
et chacun de nous
peut voir sa vie
avant que Dieu
ne rentre dans sa vie
pour nous qui étions
dans cela
une bonne nouvelle
nous a été annoncée
une guérison
nous a été donnée
pour nous
nous avons pu
constater la délivrance
combien
d'entre nous
peuvent témoigner
de certaines oppressions
de certaines choses
qu'ils vivaient
difficiles
des dépressions
de beaucoup de choses
de vie
où ils n'avaient pas la joie
et quand Christ
le soleil
de nos âmes
est rentré
comment Christ
leur a donné
la paix
et la joie
qu'ils ont recherchées
pendant des années
combien nous pouvons
témoigner
des péchés
parce que je ne vais même
pas dire les addictions
c'est ce que je disais
quand on essaie
de donner une coloration
souvent assez jolie
à ces choses
mais combien de péchés
combien nous étions
enchaînés
à certains péchés
et nous nous demandions
comment nous pouvons
même sortir
parce que nous voyons
les blessures
qu'on s'imposait
et que nous imposions
aux autres
par ces péchés
et que nous avons pu
goûter la délivrance
parce que le fils
qui s'est fait homme
la parole
qui a été faite chère
est allée jusqu'à mourir
pour nous
chaque jour
qui passe
doit être un rappel
de la grâce
du Seigneur
dans nos vies
chaque jour
qui passe
doit être un rappel
que cette parole
de l'écriture
ces paroles
qui avaient été annoncées
dans Esaïe 61
a été pleinement
accomplie
que ce
Dieu
qui est né
cet enfant
dans une étable
a choisi
volontairement
quand il était encore
dans la présence du Père
d'aller volontairement
à la croix
pour nos péchés
de mourir
volontairement
et parce qu'il a été
trouvé juste
il a été ressuscité
parce qu'il a été
trouvé juste
ressuscité
alors
Dieu
a pu épargner
un reste
que nous sommes
pour que nous puissions
contempler
la gloire
de l'éternel
et